ehi sono qua a pieni di vini
ciao velino siete pronti per una nuova
challenge e interattiva questa volta
dovremo giocare a nascondino contro il
kremlin se non avete visto gli episodi
precedenti a dove a vederli dopo questo
video vi lascio al castello il curling
equa in giro per casa
noi dobbiamo nasconderci a non farsi
trovare come funziona questo video
dovrete decidere voi sì tu proprio tu
dovrei decidere dove mi nascondo anzi
dove ci nascondiamo perché tecnicamente
saremo assieme visto che farai tu le sai
pensare hanno varie scelte durante il
video con delle caselline possono essere
due le caselline un'acqua è una cosa
possano anche essere tre un'acqua
un'acqua una guerra quanto dovrei
scegliere una di quelle caselline
saranno le varie scelte ad esempio
nasconditi dentro l'armadio nasconditi
sopra eletto dovrà essere molto attento
con le scelte perché potrebbe succedere
che il gr20 troverà e perderemo la
challenge ma non ti preoccupare perché
se perdiamo la challenge puoi
ricominciare dall'inizio e riprovare
tutte le volte che vuoi se vuoi puoi
anche provare con i tuoi amici e vedere
se vinci prima tu o i tuoi amici mi
raccomando state molto attenti alle
scelte che prenderete se questo video
raggiunge i 30 mila mi piace il prossimo
video interattivo sarà con il conte
dracula quindi lasciato un bel mi piace
per vedere un altro video interattivo ma
ora non c'è tempo da perdere
mi sono dimenticato di dirvi se non
siete ancora iscritti al canale
iscrivetevi qua sotto attivatela
campanellina per non perdermi nessun
video e qui temi su instagram lo merita
stories se volete potete seguirmi anche
su dic tocchi il nome esemplarità
stories
mettetevi comodi prendete i pop corn e
iniziamo subito la tale dove ci
nascondiamo
scegli una delle due caselline